[Music]
here in this video we will dive into 10
things in the series Monarch the legacy
of monsters that is ruining or wrecking
the most diverse lore first of all we're
not hating we are intimate fans of the
Godzilla Universe of legendary which is
why we have to be completely honest and
we have to stick it up to the lazy
riters of the show otherwise what is the
point of the comics and novelizations
the things that we have spent our money
on if everything in them are considered
non-canon this isn't the MCU for Pete's
sake there is no Multiverse here so
these 10 things would be big low
changing events we can ignore some of
the people's actions or added sequences
like Bill Randa being chased by the
mother longlegs in Skull Island as these
things could be easily fitted into the
timeline without changing the whole
overarching narrative so let's get to it
number one one they deleted the
shinamura from the timeline and changed
1954 to begin with this is the freaking
Awakening of Godzilla whereby the atomic
bombings of Hiroshima and Nagasaki
brought back the long Domin Tyrant to
the world as well as activating the
ancient shinamura from its deathlike
state okay so Awakening might create
problems as for the origin story of the
Titans and their hibernation since the
perian period which would be countered
intuitive with the ever evolving story
of The Hollow Earth and the ancient
human civilization as seen in the movies
but this could have easily been fixed
you know okay let's put that origin
story out but then they could add a few
lines regarding the shimura's existence
and that it was in fact from the hollow
Earth or also that it might have been
present with Godzilla in the Bikini atal
which would have in fact created more
urgency for the government funding for
Monarch since there would be two talents
actually spotted in the Castle Bravo
event in 1954 and not just one meaning
there are more number two so continuing
with 1954 the Godzilla scene there in
that year was too small so as to put up
a winning fight against gidora in the
ancient pars something that actually
happened see we estimated Godzilla's
size there in the series during the
bikini ATL nuclear bomb explosion we
found out that Godzilla there was only
around 300 ft or 91 M give or take a few
meters this would mean that Godzilla
would be battling a gidora that is 158.3
M or 521 ft tall which would give a
massive disadvantage to the Big G here
since even in his kotm form which was
around 120 M or 393 ft in size he was
barely able to physically overpower the
three-headed dragon imagine being 30 m
or 100 ft shorter and with a not so
powerful Atomic bread it's just
ridiculous number three the axis Mundi
is complicating the hollow Earth Map and
entry points okay so where to begin the
hollow Earth Map that Walter Simmons
showed to Nathan Lynn during GVK didn't
show any large space in between the
Surface and the hollow Earth despite
Apex having full knowledge about its
existence as of the end of the series
the new entry points all over the world
should have logically led to a place
that is at least as large as the hollow
Earth space but there isn't anything of
that sort and most of all going back to
1962 in the series the fact that project
hourglass was led by Bill Randa and this
entails a journey to the underground
realm just everything up why would
Bill Randa be researching cracks in the
ground on Skull Island for a theory in
1973 when he already had proof of the
existence of such things in 1959 in
Kazakhstan and 1962 in Kansas in the
USA number four the muto Prime might
also not be Canon anymore so there was
no mention about the queen of the mutos
in the series even though she was one of
the most powerful tyrants to have ever
existed to have hunted and killed the
guira species since the ancient times
also given that she was actually the one
that destroyed Godzilla's dosal plates
in Aftershock and forced him to grow new
ones that are bigger with a more
capacity to deal with EMP pulses or
sonic attacks of their species this
should at least be mentioned so Godzilla
was found in Algeria in 2015 a year
after the San Francisco battle and
nothing stated about his whereabouts
between those times which is OD since
Emma Russell and a lot of Monarch
operatives tracked him all over the
world from the Pacific to France and
ending in Montana USA this is the
biggest no no for the series in my
opinion I could live with the shinomura
being out of the picture but no not
prime
no number five the whole backstory of
ishiro serizawa is Rune you know I'm
just saying the main human character of
the first two Godzilla movies of this
universe has to have a different
backstory now which would further
confuse everything the guy who said let
them fight and also sacrifice his life
to revive Godzilla did get a mention in
the series but how how he came to be a
part of Monarch is all tight to the
shinamura and the Godzilla Awakening
events as it was his father who
witnessed the tirans in Japan for the
first time ever and became the founding
member of Monarch who then eventually
devoted these secrets to his son ishiro
and then when a serizawa died this would
motivate ishiro serizawa to join up with
the elusive organization to study and
monitor the Titans number six Apex in
Skull Island is just freaking confusing
what are they doing there and how did
they get clearance to be in the island
the place where only monarch was
supposed to have facilities or outposts
to monitor the giant creatures and
monsters of the island there also seems
to be a huge storm over the island which
I am hoping isn't the Perpetual one that
was introduced in the events of Kingdom
Kong by cods Otherwise this is just
hopeless it will just ruin the timeline
of kotm and Kingdom Kong and then GVK
and the rest since the scene there in
the series was in
2017 while gdor awakened the Titans in
2019 and that czos attracted the
remnants of Monster Zero Storm over the
island in
20121 4 years later so that's that now
coming to number seven the whole origin
story of Monarch and their struggle for
funding and existence in the early years
up to 1973 is now void as per the series
the organization began in 1952 with Lee
Shaw Bill Randa and koiko as the
founders but the actual lower behind the
series states that Monarch was founded
in secrecy in around the late 1940s as a
Japanese American quasi governmental
Coalition in order to study and Hunt
massive unidentified terrestrial
organisms it was actually President
Truman who established a research team
called monar unit with ag serizawa in it
as the actual
Founders number eight the USS Lord and
incident Paradox yeah so this was an
incident that bill Randle was involved
in this incident took place in the ocean
near PE Harbor in 1943 and was
explicitly stated by Bill Randa in 1973
that there were claw marks everywhere
and there is also a photo of it from one
of the opening scenes of one of the most
diverse movies but here in this series
the ship was in the middle of the
Philippines dragged Inland by the Iron
Dragon how a talent that was at that
time in 1952 was barely as big as the
skull devil how would it drag an entire
ship a destroyer
inside an island good luck making sense
of this one maybe it went to the axis
monai and maybe came back up with it who
knows you know beyond logic was the last
episode's name and it should have been
the name of the entire series number
nine let's take a look at the temporal
or time anomaly in the axis mondi okay
so we're just getting crazy and crazy as
it goes right it's one day in the axis
mandai that is equivalent to one year on
the surface seems lazy but okay but what
about the hollow Earth that the
characters following Kong and GVK
actually time traveled and did
Godzilla's Atomic breath in Hong Kong
last days on the surface when only it
was just a few seconds of its
destruction as was seen in the throne
room of the Kongs how would this equate
let's say Kong and the others traveled
half a day in the hollow Earth did
Godzilla take half a year to reach Hong
Kong you know to B Kong in Hong Kong
wild right just
wild and lastly number 10 Titans aren't
about size they're about radiation or
something else I'll just leave this here
as an ominous Point Titans and year
before 2019 they were called mutos
massive unidentified terrestrial
organisms not Titans Okay so now we have
come to the end of this video this rant
of mine uh regarding the moners and
monar the legacy of monsters which I'm
now considering isn't a part of the
monsterverse it's just a spoof like you
know scary movies
now if you like this video then watch
this other one as well and do check out
our Channel as we might have other mon
of us content that you might like to see
like subscribe and we'll see you in the
next video take care fam